kevin gausman as he is coming off his
start against the los angeles dodgers
where he was very good
he's got options he's either going to go
up or throw him a split
looks like from the signs he's going to
try and go up
payoff goes up and this time the high
fastball gets olsen
sean manaya who makes his fifth start of
the year a ballooning nine
era thus far and this is a guy the a's
absolutely have to get going
to one to yastrimsky there's a big cut
going the other way but playable
for robbie grossman and sean manaya good
sign for him as he works a 1-2-3
first here's the pitch now swung on and
missed he struck him out came back with
that splitter again
one two pitch swing and a miss
he struck him out and that was this
there's that same swing dave
two and two the count two down nobody on
here it is
he's struck him out swinging strike out
the side
inning for gausman and he has struck out
going back to the first
four in a row this has to be one of my
absolute
favorite names in the league female
machines playing in his fifth major
league game third career start
and he lifts this one into left field
that'll get down for a base hit in front
of rough
there is the first major league base hit
for machine they're gonna get that
baseball and uh that'll be
a great moment for this young man always
remember your first one adam and
he gets a heater up 96 and not high
enough
marcus simeone went off a career year
last year where he was
third in the american league mvp vote
and the 3-1 and that is hit well to
center field
yustrepski's going back toward the track
near the wall still going and out
into the bullpen for marcus simeon a
drive to center off of guzman with a man
on
and the a's jumped to a two-nothing lead
on simeon's
second home run of the year
you know it sounded like it was going to
be exactly what it was two and two to
donovan solano
here's the pitch solano lights wanted to
left field base hit
a solid line drive single that's a
17-game hit streak
for donovan solano the giants with two
on and nobody out
and mike ustremski coming to the plate
been one of the best hitters
in the big leagues so far this year one
two
just sends it to right that's towards
the wall and that's down
cut off by piscotty and he has some
trouble with it that's going to get to
the wall
and that's going to score two for the
giants yastrimsky in the third
that ball gets away and into the dugout
and your strip c is going to get home
plate
just like that the giants have the lead
i thought biscotti also had cut the ball
off but adam he gets kind of wiggles by
him
he overruns it a little bit and then the
relay is when the fun really begins
simeon tough play for chapman into the
runner and then trickles into the dugout
for the little league home run the fifth
inning
the way they mania's fourth fifth
innings have gone
this year gosman needs to get his boys
back in there swing the bat again
allen chases that split in the dirt toss
down to first for what will be
strikeout number eight for gaussman you
start pressing as a player i don't care
who you are
oh and he waves at that good off speed
delivery again nine strikeouts for
gaussman 02.
and he got him with that diving pitch
that he's had all day
10 strikeouts guzman fans the side
you go to the sixth inning and here's
those
olson in the air well struck to center
yastremski back at the track turning
around and watching it go
the last seven hits for matt olson have
all been home runs his eighth shot of
the year
and this game is tied at three
all he does is hit home runs
[Applause]
in the left down the line and that will
get down for a base hit
it'll be an easy lead-off double for
evan longoria here in the seventh inning
and the go-ahead run is a boarding
scoring position for the giants
balls that smith's been throwing
longoria just gets the head out rips his
ball down the left field line for an
easy lead off double for the giants
first pitch swinging and he sends it
towards right center field long run for
canna it's down for a base hit
longoria had to hold up to see if he
could make the catch so he'll only get
into third
but it's runners at the corners and
nobody out for the giants in the seventh
rough cruise back in america after
spending the last three years being one
of the top power hitters
in korea here's a 2-2
swing and a drive to left field back on
it grossman
and it is just over the wall and gone
left with a three-run go-ahead shot off
bert smith
in the seventh the giants have a 6-3
lead
about all his home runs and a ball
right down the middle belt high trying
to throw it up above his back
rough gets the barrel there puts his
ball out into the left center for a
three run lead for the giants
shawn murphy and then the top first
pitch swinging
murphy to center ranging back to bond at
the track
leeb said it's out of here
solo shot sean murphy
and there are some nervous giants fans
right now
still a two-run lead but nobody out of
the night franklin's at first that's the
tying run tony kemps at third two out
ninth inning
astral six four count as a right hand to
hitter
six to four giants the payoff cannon
swings and sends one to left field
back is just at the track and it's gone
they've done it again marcano delivers
and the a's have taken a ninth-inning
lead once more back-to-back games the
a's have gotten up off the deck in the
ninth
and now they take the lead a three-run
home run
seven six a's over the giants
hendricks home with an o2 dubois pops it
up
kemp underneath they came back with
five of the ninth last night to win in
extra innings
they come back with four in the ninth
tonight